In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion for July 18 on which we commemorate our venerable Father
Pambol, born in about the year 304, the Great Pambol was a disciple of Saint Antony before
going to dwell in the desert of Nithria, to the west of the Nile Delta, where he remained
until the end of his days.
Saint Antony said of him, through fearing God, he caused the Spirit of God to dwell in him.
For this reason, he was able to form other God-bearing fathers in the ascetic and mystical
life, among whom were the tall brothers.
He was ordained priest and outstanding monks like Saint Macarios traveled long distances
on foot to be present at the liturgy when he celebrated.
Living in great poverty himself, Pambol taught that a monk must be able to leave the garment
he wore outside his cell for three days without anyone wishing to take it.
He spoke little, and when he was asked for a word, or about the interpretation of a passage
from the Holy Scriptures, he would not reply immediately, but would sometimes wait for
three months before giving the answer that God had given him.
His words were heavy with meaning, and it was said of him that the gift he had received
of penetrating the Holy Scriptures surpassed even that of Saint Antony.
On the day the demons wishing to make Pambol laugh, he, who never so much as smiled, tied
a feather to the end of a piece of wood, and began to carry it around, making a great
din. Pambol began to laugh. Yet far from being overcome, he turned to the demons who were about
to celebrate their victory and retorted, I have not laughed, but I have made fun of your powerlessness
because it takes so many of you to carry a wing.
When he had gone to Alexandria, he saw an actress who was catching the eye of those who passed by,
and he began to weep. To those who asked him, the reason for his tears, he replied,
two things make me weep, the loss of this woman, and the other that I am not so concerned
to please God as she is to please wicked men. For three years, Abba Pambol begged God not to glorify him
on earth. Yet God glorified him to such an extent that it was not possible to look directly at him
for the divine glory shown from his face, like the face of the Prophet Moses after the revelation
on Sinai. Melania the Elder, who had heard people speak of Abba Pambol's virtue,
traveled from Rome to Alexandria, and then to Nitria, in the company of the priest Isador,
the hospitaler, in the year 374. She placed 300 pounds of silver at the feet of the
Elder, who continued to weave his palm leaves, and simply said to her, may God give you your reward.
He then ordered one of his disciples to distribute the money to the brethren in Libya,
and the islands, and not in Egypt, for the latter region was more fertile. Melania,
who had hoped to receive a word from Abba Pambol, reminded him that she had given him 300 pounds
and that it was a considerable sum. Pambol replied, without lifting up his head.
He, to whom you have brought the gold, has no need of scales, my child.
He who weighs the mountains knows well what this silver is worth.
In truth, if it is to me that you bring it, you would do well to say so, but if it is to God,
to him who did not disdain the widow's two coppers, you do well to remain silent.
A little later, the saint, aged 70, began to weaken, and he said to his disciples,
since I came to this desert and built this cell, I do not remember having eaten bread that was
not the work of my hands. And until now, I have not had to repent of a single word I uttered.
Yet I am going to God, as one who has not yet begun to serve him.
He fell asleep in peace in the presence of Saint Melania, to whom he gave the basket that he had been
in the process of weaving. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.